[Music]
[Laughter]
hey what's up everyone
i'm naji jeter i'm playing miles morales
and marvel's spider-man miles morales
miles game is a continuation of the
first spider-man game
you'll see miles's new powers his world
who he really is his family what he's
all about
hey dude i am so filling your suit with
snow
are you still wearing your suit yeah you
know just in case
so miles personal growth and story is
rooted in tragedy just like the other
spiderman
in the comics i think that the death of
miles dad
affected him greatly
i think miles was a little lost he was
impacted in an emotional way and he
looked to his dad
and then that hero is gone i think
what's most exciting about miles
new abilities is the fact that the story
is really
centered around how does miles become
his own spider-man
alongside but separate from peter
parker's spider-man
so miles and pete do share some similar
powers
but miles has camouflage as little venom
powers
is a little faster he's going to feel
different from from
the previous spider-man
see this is my favorite part of living
in harlem
pop-up street fair best food in the city
awesome music
living in brooklyn because that's where
we lived as a family
it's a painful reminder of our life
together
so we go back to spanish harlem we get
an apartment
being in spanish harlem he becomes a
whole new person he has to adjust to
new friends to a new culture to a new
community
from what i've seen of spanish harlem
it's both rugged and
beautiful you really get connected to
the lifeline of this part of the city
and and what's going on
miles what's the underground doing
they're after new form
every great hero there's always a
villain
let's not shoot each other all right
the villains in the game give miles the
pressure
put them on his toes get him thinking
all the time
so on the outside roxanne's motivations
appear to be helpful and positive
you're gonna have a love and hate
relationship with him you'll get to find
out in the game
who they really are what they're really
about we think we have roxanne as the
only enemy
and then roxanne has other enemies but
they're not
necessarily after the same goals that we
as the community
and spanish harlem are
the underground is no good they have a
leader that
miles not too fond of
they've come in not just to threaten
roxanne but to threaten us
now we're dealing with some really scary
stuff
the game is action-packed exciting
no really emotional
we are going to get the fans on their
toes man i am
definitely looking forward to playing
this game we cannot wait
it's gonna be mind-blowing i'm telling
you
playstation